a couple of people came up to me good
political people they said you know
going to the NRA convention and speaking
to the dead of America diversion you
know but I said get on the plane
it was a campaign style rally with a
familiar feel a little politics news of
the day and like his three previous
speeches to the National Rifle
Association a heavy emphasis on the
right to bear arms we will never give up
afraid Americans are born free
we will live free and we will die free
but the president's fourth address of
the powerful pro-gun group comes amid
increasingly polarized attitudes about
guns across the country particularly in
the wake of a spate of mass shootings in
Las Vegas at a church community in Texas
and just two months ago the horror that
struck parkland Florida and left 17
people dead a tragedy that spawned
dozens of March for our lives events
across the country in the wake of that
shooting the president challenged
lawmakers to stand up to the gun lobby
and he said he'd do the same to reduce
it great people do too great Patriots
they love our country but that doesn't
mean we have to agree or don't it
doesn't make sense that I have to wait
till I'm 21 to get a handgun but I can
get this weapon at 18 while it's true
the president followed up by hosting
several listening sessions proposed a
ban on bump stocks raising the age limit
to buy a gun 221 even advocated for
universal background checks today much
to the dismay of some Democratic
lawmakers it was a much different tone
long uncivil but short on solutions
the NRA always likes to talk about
freedom no one is talking about taking
away the freedom of gun owners but we
have to remember the freedom of the 17
kids the 14 students the teachers that
were gunned down at Stoneman Douglas
their freedom matters too John let me
tell you this vice president Mike Pence
also delivered a rousing address to the
gathering here in fact he the President
and just about every other major speaker
employing the gathering to be sure to
vote this summer this fall in 2018 or
risk the Democrats taking control of
Congress and ultimately losing their gun
rights forever